you're very popular in England you are
they love you in England what's it been
like transitioning to the United States
you come here you have a very you can be
sarcastic yes and you like to mix it up
you like to get in people's faces and
say things in front of the press how has
that been received well listen at the
end of the day we're gonna fight if I've
got an opponent I'm gonna try and get
them to doubt themselves so yeah you
know I mean I say a few things here and
there now if an American comes to
England to fight me they get booed so
when I've been here you guys
you haven't really show much love but
that's fair enough you know because if
I'm found an American in America I
expect to be booed that's sir you know
it stands you thrive on it a little bit
when they're boo is nice I like I prefer
it anything as long as as long whether
the cheer or the boom yeah as long as
they don't just go yeah yeah exactly
this guy yeah yeah let me tell you about
the monologue all right I had this one
joke a vending machine sea oysters
nothing these people gave me nothing
[Applause]
they were knocked out yeah doesn't count
now
you